hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar titled practical tips to manage
laboratory qc data i'm susie valdez of
labyrinths and i will be your moderator
for today's event
this educational web seminar is
sponsored by bio rad
laboratories i want to invite everyone
to participate by submitting as many
questions as you want
during the presentation to do so simply
type them into the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
and click send
any questions we do not have time for
during the webinar
will be captured and responded through
the q a
list that will be posted next week in
the event resource box which is located
below the ask a question box you will
also be able to download the
presentation handouts from this event
resource box
starting on may 20th if you have any
technical trouble seeing or hearing this
presentation
simply contact us through the ask a
question box
and we'll be able to address those
issues as a reminder
this presentation is educational and
offers free pace
continuing education credits click on
the continuing
education credits tab located at the top
right hand corner of your presentation
window and follow
the instructions to obtain those credits
so let's get started i want to introduce
our presenter
today dr james nichols dr nichols is a
professor of pathology
microbiology and immunology the medical
director of clinical chemistry
and point-of-care testing at vanderbilt
university school of medicine
he is a board-certified and both
clinical chemistry and toxicological
chemistry by the american board of
clinical chemistry
dr nichols research interests span
evidence-based
medicine information management
laboratory automation
point of care testing and toxicology dr
nichols is currently
also the president-elect of the clinical
laboratory standard institute
or clc clsi and has been a member
chair holder and advisor of several clsi
document
development committees for complete
biography of dr nichols please visit the
biography tab
at the top of your screen dr nichols
welcome you may now begin your
presentation sir
well thank you for that introduction and
it's a pleasure to be here today to talk
to you about
practical tips to manage laboratory qc
data the objectives today i'm going to
review
quality control data for shifts and
trends
we're going to critically assess
laboratory performance against
peers and i'll show you how to do that
and we're going to identify the danger
of making frequent
qc adjustments
much of what i'm going to be discussing
comes straight out of
clsi c24 the statistical
quality control for quantitative
measurement procedures
principles and definitions that was
published by clsi
in 2016.
i'd like to start with some definitions
quality assurance is that entire
umbrella
of all of the activities that we do in
the laboratory
in the pre-analytic analytic
post-analytic phases
to promote excellent outcomes in medical
care
and good quality test results quality
control is just
a component under that quality assurance
umbrella but it's an integral part
of the aggregate of processes and
techniques
that we do to detect reduce and correct
deficiencies
in an analytical process quality
improvement on the other hand is
benchmarking
benchmarking our performance and
continually
assessing and adjusting our performance
using statistically
and scientifically accepted procedures
now the iso definition 5.6.2 point
from iso 15189
indicates that the laboratory shall
design internal
control systems that verified the
attainment of
intended quality of test results special
attention should be paid to the
elimination of mistakes in the process
of
handling specimens requests examinations
reports and other parts of the total
testing process documentation should
include
quality control procedures based on the
manufacturer's instructions for use
or the package insert internal quality
control by this definition
is that liquid qc that
those processes and analysis that we do
in the laboratory that's internal
to our laboratory as opposed to
proficiency
testing which i'll describe later in
this talk
internal quality control is defined as
that set of procedures
undertaken by the laboratory staff for
the continuous monitoring of operation
and the results of measurements in order
to decide whether we release
results and whether they're reliable
enough for patient care
the regular analysis of quality control
materials
serves as an essential component of our
laboratory's internal control system
now used to be we would test patient
samples
in batch we would put quality control
before
and after those patient test samples and
we would test them as part of this batch
we'd hold results until we finished the
total run analysis and then we would
release those results
now we're dealing with automated systems
where we have tracks where these traps
move samples around between analyzers
and everything is continuously released
in process so as soon as we analyze a
sample
we're releasing those results to the
clinicians
so the modern laboratory is very much
run
like a factory
and as part of this we have to adopt
quality control processes and think much
more in
the factory model now historically
quality control was born
in the 1900s industrial models of
quality in the analytical process
in a factory we're building airlines or
uh car parts and we're looking as
these uh parts come down or the
automobile
is coming down the factory line we're
inspecting it to make sure that it meets
certain specifications
as we do with laboratory testing we're
adding samples
called quality control that are tested
very much
like a patient sample and the results of
those
are then analyzed to
determine that the analytical system is
achieving the desired result
that the quality control result is
within
pre-specified limits if it is
then our system is stable and we assume
we're producing quality patient results
now some definitions i want to go
through accuracy or trueness
are descriptions of the extent to which
our
measurement results approach the true
value
and the parameter of accuracy that we
measure
is bias or difference from truth
precision on the other hand is
reproducibility
on the repeated measurement of the same
sample
standard deviation is our parameter of
measurement
for precision
if we randomly uh analyze a specimen
repeatedly
over time all of those results
should scatter around a mean
and within two standard deviations of
that mean
form a bell-shaped curve in other words
95 of the data under this
bell shape or gaussian distribution
should fall within two standard
deviations of the mean
three standard deviations is about 99.7
of the data so most of our quality
control
ranges are set up to plus or minus 2sd
as is our reference intervals and other
aspects of what we do in the laboratory
we use the two standard deviation ranges
in quality control
for setting up and estimating future
performance in other words
we can measure over a period of several
days
a particular quality control sample
achieve a mean
and a range of data around that mean
and within two sds we can predict future
performance if we continue to analyze
that sample
or samples from that same quality
control lot
so if we plot these we can see
most of the samples on this plot here
fall within the mean is the black big
black bar in the middle
3.48 for this glucose
and most of the plots within the first
half of this
graph fall within plus or minus two
standard deviations
the orange dashed bars
however somewhere around the middle of
the plot on day
16 to 17 we see a shift
where we have that red uh box
and that allows us visually to see
a shift or trend in our data and to take
corrective actions
as appropriate now traditionally we have
set up
multi uc rules
to determine whether our analyzer is
stable and releasing good quality
patient test results or whether we need
to stop patient testing
and take corrective action rules such as
1
2s are set up more as warning rules
because remember 95 of the data under
that bell shaped
gaussian curve falls within
plus or minus 2sd but we have those
outliers of 5
just by random chance that's one out of
20
uh test results could just randomly be
due
uh to chance so if
however we have a 1 3s failure our
quality control outside of 3sd that's
very
improbable that it's random and this
must be some shift in the performance of
our
test system because a 1 3s
three standard deviations encompasses
99.7
so randomly only one out of 300
test results would fall outside of those
limits
so we're looking more at some type of
shift or an inaccuracy or imprecision
within our test method
and we can apply other types of rules
such as 2 2s 4s
where four consecutive points exceed one
standard deviation
or even 10 consecutive points on one
side of the mean
the selection of rules that a laboratory
uses depends on your quality goals
and the tolerance you have for
troubleshooting
if you set them too tight you will
overcall many many failures
and be troubleshooting the method more
than you need to
in other words false alarms if you set
the
ranges too wide you uh the method will
not be sensitive
to picking up big shifts or trends that
could affect
patient uh results so you want just that
right
range and the methods that different
laboratories utilize
varies there is no one right way or
wrong way
to address uh troubleshooting and
setting up your targets
but i'll give you some tips based on c24
to help assist with this throughout this
talk
you may be familiar with westgard's uh
chart
for troubleshooting and determining
whether quality control is
in range or out of range and whether it
is acceptable to continue
to release results or to stop testing
and troubleshoot
now it's important that we look at our
quality control data
continuously as we run quality control
whether it be periodically every so many
hours
or so many patients on a continuous run
every 20
50 100 patients depending on the
performance of that assay
it's important that bench techs look and
assess that quality control performance
as soon as the results are available so
they should verify that qc
is recorded in an electronic system
if it is outside of limits they should
stop patient testing
troubleshoot failed quality controls and
document their corrective actions
if necessary because we're releasing
results continuously on our automated
platforms like hematology and chemistry
analyzers
we want to go back and do a patient look
back since the last previous
good qc or acceptable in range
quality control we also want to check
for shifts
and trends in other words has our
quality control data
shifted very close to the two sd or
three sd
limits whichever rule your laboratory is
using and is just hovering there
which may indicate that there's been
some change in performance
since we initially set up those target
ranges
we then want to ensure that there is a
periodic review
by the leadership of the laboratory
litex managers ensuring that
the bench techs have documented failures
and investigation of those failures
and that patient look backs are
documented in action taken
correcting results if necessary
they also want to look for assay bias
precision
and shifts and trends and the medical
directors should sign off on these at
least
on a monthly basis or periodically
depending on the
policies of that laboratory and your
local regulations
you should be looking at the qc charts
looking to make sure that
troubleshooting has been documented and
assess performance against your peers
we put out in our laboratory and post
a troubleshooting table to assist our
bench techs
in how to troubleshoot out of range qc
first we recommend going back and
repeating the quality control and this
isn't just the level that
failed if we're running two or three
levels of qc
we want the entire event to be repeated
and make sure that all three of those
levels
if we are running three level multiple
level qc
is within range if it is we can stop
troubleshooting if not we can go on and
look to
a fresh package of reagent from the same
lot
we should then be checking for
calibration when was the last time the
assay was calibrated is it very close to
outdating or has the calibration expired
we also want to look to
after calibration maybe changing reagent
lots
or checking for other calibrator lots
before we
go on to looking at instrument
maintenance
troubleshooting the analyzer as parts
and calling the manufacturer in
for repairs so this is a general
uh overview of how to approach
troubleshooting
out of range qc
as i review qc as the medical director
i'm looking for shifts out of control
qc that detect unstable performance
because this then leads to the
possibility for reporting
erroneous patient results the first step
i want texts to do
anytime they have an out of range data i
want them to stop patient testing and
troubleshoot
as i'm looking at the monthly
uh report i'm looking at graphs i i look
for
shifts which is a sudden change in the
qc
i'm also looking for trends where it's
downward or
upward and downward as i've circled here
in this plot
so a trend occurring gradually over time
in reagent or control degradation kind
of a
point uh pinpointing that this may have
occurred
or a sudden shift where we may have
shifted lots or we may have recalibrated
that caused a shift in the performance
of our analyzer and test method
now many factors can cause errors and
test results
reagent degradation which exposure to
temperature
light humidity calibrators and controls
can go bad as they're stored even in the
refrigerator or
after we open a bottle and we repeatedly
utilize
the liquid in that bottle it can be
exposed to air
the analyte can shift in stability over
time
so if we repeatedly run quality control
out of a single vial over time
we can see degradations in performance
due to evaporation
or even analyte stability so we need to
think about how
many times can we utilize a bottle of qc
or even a calibrator after reopening it
can those calibrators be re-frozen and
re-thawed
which may affect performance as well
instrument maintenance is important to
keep up
daily weekly monthly
periodic semi-annual and annual
maintenance
needs to be done as specified by the
manufacturer
in their instructions for use but also
if you
have a very high volume throughput
of specimen samples you may need to up
the frequency of your maintenance
because you may see wear and tear
and failure of parts before the
manufacturer recommended maintenance
cycle
personnel we have to think about
training competency
is are they operating the analyzer
correctly
and are they making inadvertent mistakes
how can we prevent those
in the training process
now laboratory errors come in two
flavors systematic errors
lead from a shift in performance or a
bias
from one point forward in time can be a
problem with
calibration incorrect set points of the
calibrators the standard
that was used are reagents blanks
controls random errors however
occur with a single sample and are not
persistent in time
things like clots bubbles
drug interferences or hemolysis
for instance in that sample
now systematic errors are easier to
detect
with quality control because the
analyzer performance affects the quality
control sample
the same way it affects patient samples
with these persistent errors over time
or shifts and performance however a
random error
occurs with one single sample and that's
much more
hard harder or insidious to detect with
the quality control
as we think of our corrective actions
think of making it simple for your
technologists
and for the management team have
charts like i showed earlier or
diagrams like this in your policies and
procedures
to methodically address key sources of
analytical performance
such as quality control first then
addressing reagent then calibrate then
the potential for analyzer breakdown or
operator error do these one at a time as
you troubleshoot
and that will allow you to
systematically come in
to the source of that problem
excuse me once the source is discovered
and the issue is resolved you should
look back
at patient uh results since the last
good qc or in range result performance
to ensure that patients uh results that
were released were correct
and that you don't need to correct a
result and contact a physician
as i review through our quality control
i'm looking for shifts in a single level
of qc
here you can see very close to the mean
performance
at the beginning of the chart leading to
a shift
almost 1 sd near the middle of the
church
step behavior where we see sudden ships
up and then down
in performance or shifts in all three
levels
of quality control here you can see a
decrease
in the ranges for all three levels
we also can look for changes in
performance because not all of our
problems
are ships in bias we could see increase
in precision in our method and here you
can see right around where that black
line is in the first and abrupt change
in the precision of our method
we look for things where we have stable
performance
and suddenly now seesaw performance
where you may have two bottles of
the same reagent on the analyzer at the
same time
but because they're calibrated at
different time points
they have different biases so your qc
ships from
up down up down as you do
that you see events or you can look for
just generally
poor performance
now we also look for incorrect
comments and uh incorrect address
um troubleshooting comments from our
text where they have
accepted um uh out of range qc
when it should have been a failure and
they should have troubleshooted this
such as accepting a 1 2 s warning but
it's
actually a 2 2 s because it followed a 1
3s
so it is outside of 2s successively
frequent 1 2s warnings with no action
as an issue shows that we may have had a
shift in that qc
close to being out of range and the text
will accept it when it's in range but
the very next
analysis of that qc it's out of range
and they're troubleshooting again
this means we really should be
troubleshooting system performance
and not just trying to squeak the qc
back in
or you may have an incorrect comment
such as
a 2 1 2 s warning followed by
another level of qc also being outside
on the next performance and analysis
again another definition of 2 2s
we also want to look for bias to the
mean
and all three levels of our quality
control such as here
where we see a shift up in all three
levels
over a period of time
now i mentioned patient look back let's
talk about that a little bit closer
and in more detail patient look back is
when we retest patients we've had a
failure
in our qc it's out of range we're
troubleshooting it
we fix whatever the problem is now we
want to go backwards
in time and make sure that all of the
patients we resulted
since the previous qc were acceptable
you if you do a high volume of testing
you may want to start with every 10th or
20th patient
just looking backwards in time am i
recovering the same
test results or is it significantly
different
if we find differences we may have to go
back and correct
that result contact the physician
hopefully we have
the sample because we detect it right
away
but if we're reviewing a week later
samples have been eliminated or
discarded
we may need to comment that result
contact the physician and let them know
that the results
of the sample is no longer available for
retesting
that they should review the clinical
relevance
of that test and look at it and suspect
it
as potentially being incorrect
so look at clinical correlation
in other words
now part of a quality management system
is quality control
and we focus on fulfilling those quality
requirements in the laboratory
what are those quality requirements
they're specified by total allowable
error or biologic variation for a
particular analyte
if the measurement error exceeds a
patient results and the total allowable
error that result fails to meet
patient care needs or quality
requirements for laboratory
so our quality of the testing process qc
ensures that the analytical variability
meets the accuracy
and precision requirements established
for that
test are always appropriate for patient
care
now defining total allowable error
versus total analytical error
our total allowable error is the medical
utility
the biologic variation of that analyte
glucose sodium the total analytical
error
is our method error um
in this tae versus tea
now medical usefulness should be wider
and must be greater than the analytical
performance
of our method otherwise the test is not
meeting patient care needs
in other words our total analytical
error is our bias
and two times our standard deviation or
our coefficient of variation
now our total allowable error is
determined from medical decision points
and biologic variability
this biologic variability we can look up
in
uh there's references and consensus
guidelines for this
one of the most recent ones here is the
ricoh standard
we have biologic variation and desirable
analytical specification
for different analytes either
serum urine plasma in this table
now total analytical error
is our tae
is our bias and two standard deviations
and it's
a gaussian curve around the mean
uh performance of that analyzer for a
given test
and you can see here it's a bell-shaped
blue
curve the mean of that curve is
the blue line and the true value or
truth
is the big black bar so we have
systematic error
which is our bias and we have random
error
which is the range or the the
width of that bell-shaped curve
we want our total allowable
error to in the red bars
to be much wider than the analytical
performance of our analyzer
in this bell-shaped blue curve
otherwise uh
we aren't meeting clinical performance
so having a much wider biologic
variation
or total allowable error allows our
analytical performance to shift slightly
from one day to the next or one
calibration
to the next calibration without
going outside of our allowable limits
okay our quality control ranges should
be based on the observed instrument
variability
rather than manufacturer recommendations
a lot of the ranges that are distributed
in the package insert are much wider
than even biologic variation for that
particular test
so glucose for instance a normal control
in the manufactured packaging
might be 50 to 150 milligrams per
deciliter
but our analyzer with the performance of
one and a half
percent cv gives us an overall if we
estimate
zero bias overall total analytical error
of plus or minus three percent
this means if we repeatedly measure that
quality control sample
and get a value of 100 our 2sd
range is going to be 97 to 103
for that particular quality control
biologic variation for glucose on the
other hand is closer to seven percent
so you can see that our analyzer total
analytical error
is much tighter than the total allowable
error
of seven percent and both of these are
well within manufacturer uh
suggested ranges of 50 to 150 for this
given control
this is why a laboratory performing
quantitative
quality control statistical procedures
wants to set their own target ranges
based on their
test system performance
rather than just adopt what's in the
package insert
now we do need to be concerned about
commutability because
oftentimes the suggested quality control
target ranges in the package insert
are based on multiple different
analyzers either
models of analyzer and even different
manufacturers
quality control materials remember
though contain stabilizers
and preservatives to extend the shelf
life of that material
and the stability of that analyte in
this in the matrix
this alters the matrix of quality
control samples compared to
biological samples and they may behave
differently than patient samples
so clsi recommends
analyzing new qc lots once a day
at a minimum for 10 days there's also
ep05 that notes that 20 days of
performance
may be required to get a better estimate
of all the different contributions from
periodic
and occasional sources of variability
that contribute to a measurement
procedure's long-term performance
ultimately it comes up to the laboratory
director and this is where i mentioned
that individual laboratories may set the
ranges slightly differently
they may validate new lot
a little bit differently as well so it
is clearly up to the medical director
and based on your experience
with a particular product you may
shorten
your verification when you get new lots
in
can be either 10 20 it's at the
determination of
the medical director and some analytes
have much more stable performance than
others and so that may require a little
bit longer
performance before you set your
new ranges now ultimately over time
we want our quality control supply to
last long enough that we can actually
get
a good estimate of test system
performance
we want to look at multiple calibrations
the effect of changing reagent lots
environment maintenance even seasonal
differences
in our analyzer from winter to summer
humidity and temperature variations in
the laboratory can affect
certain analyte performances so we want
our supply to be stable enough over a
longer term
period of time to get a good estimate of
whether
our performance is in range or
shifting now this brings me back to our
case
i remember taking over a laboratory
where the
lead tech in that area would
move and change the qc ranges
every month as part of their monthly
review
they thought this was part of monthly
review but i'll tell you that frequent
range adjustments sort of defeats the
purpose of running quality control
because you've set up an expectation
that this particular control will fall
within a particular
range and you're estimating stable
performance
versus unstable performance and need to
troubleshoot
based on that range if you consistently
and continuously change
the range every time you go through a
review
that then is shifting your expectations
of performance
and you really can't judge true
performance of your analyzer
so you want to establish a historical
performance
over a longer period of time several
months calibrations of reagent changes
to detect and be sensitive to shifts and
biases that may affect patient test
results
so let's turn to a couple of examples
before the end of this talk
here we have a new home assisting
quality control lot
and we need to set new ranges our
package insert
has uh ranges of plus or minus
approximately 25 to
30 percent at the three levels of qc
we analyze an eloqua of each of these
levels
once a day for 20 days we use the ep05
recommendation
because we want to get some estimate of
different operators
different instruments in our laboratory
and different calibrations
this is the result of this so
historically over time we've been
running
and here you can see uh current qc up in
the upper right hand corner
it we are running at nine percent at 7.7
and the high q 6
total allowable error for this
biological is 15.5 percent
we run this qc over 20 days on four
different analyzers so we get 80 points
here
and these are our means um in the upper
left
box here 7.17 13.13
26.12 so the new
lot ranges have to take into account
that
the qc may be slightly different in
terms of mean
but since we've had stable performance
at
this standard deviation we want to keep
the same cvs
and adopt the new ranges so we set
our level 1 where the cv is the same
7.2 plus or minus 0.65
this is 9 and that's
still nine percent cv but the sd has
changed a little bit
down from point seven because the mean
shifted
level two qc didn't shift at all means
the same
so we keep the sd the same and the cv
7.7 percent
and level three 26.12
is very close to 25. uh we kept the
standard deviation the same which
narrows our cv
just a little bit so
that's how we adopt and verify
a new reagent and set new ranges when we
get a new lot of qc what about a new lot
of reagent
we pull some samples measure them in the
old lot and the new lot
so we're looking at patient samples that
spam the reportable range
of that test and we want to look at qc
old lot versus new lot of reagent
here you can see five patients old
versus new lot
controls old versus new and we can see
that everything
engagement lot changes shouldn't shift
controls unless there's a matrix effect
matrix effect would be something like
the lower left box where you see
a big shift in the high qc no shift in
the low qc
when you adopt and implement a new
a lot of reagent
now this is an interesting one it's ige
we have a level 1 qc the new lot was
close to the lower limit of acceptance
147 is our lower limit of um
that level one uh qc
uh we got a level of 140 or
348. so
um 347 versus 348 it's almost
out so do we accept this new reagent
or do we request a new lot of reagent
well because they only ran this once i
requested that uh they go back
repeat the qc this time it came up much
closer uh 382 towards the mean of 425
that we have set
and then to recalibrate and repeat qc
and lo and behold it pops right onto the
mean
so it was just an issue of randomly
lying almost out and on repeat it came
much closer to the mean
and then on recalibration it's right at
the mean so
don't always reject a reagent lot just
based on the initial qc performance
run it a couple of times try
troubleshooting quality
of your calibrator and your
repeating of the qc before you reject
a lot we have peer down here
and you can look at how our performance
in the laboratory
compares against peers over time and
i'll talk about that
in a slide or two now
advisors in our laboratory say five
chemistry analyzers
how do we set our quality control do we
set an individual mean and range
for each and every analyzer which would
give us analyzer one
say for instance albumin two point four
four
analyzer two two point four one analyzer
three two point four
zero analyzer 4 2.46 and so forth
or do we set a group mean based on the
entire laboratory
maybe slightly wider sd and cv
but it encompasses all of the the
analyzers
i would say it's easier for the
technologist
to set one mean and to to keep that and
think about it
but if you have smart uh technologies
your computer systems you may be able to
set more
individualized analyzer performance
ranges
you want to periodically review your
means
sd cvs to ensure appropriate ranges
identify changes in method performance
that may require corrective actions
certainly investigate measurement
procedures that have frequent qc
failures
redetermine whether you've had a shift
in the performance
or a deterioration in your reagent or
even the quality control material itself
so look to peers
monitor the rate of qc rule rejections
your number of patient samples
needing retesting review your analytical
errors not detected using statistical qc
to help you develop a better qc strategy
and better appropriate multi-quality
control rules
supplement your quality control with
external proficiency
testing or eqa an external quality
assurance program
this allows you to participate in
inter-laboratory
both specimens that have a known value
or that you're comparing to your peers
as well as a laboratory quality control
performance
where you have multiple laboratories
running the same lot of quality control
that you can compare against because
they're from the same manufacturer
assays and analyzers
the benefits of these interlaboratory qc
comparison
is that your package insert quality
control ranges are often very wide
cover many lots different test methods
and instruments
a quality control comparison provides
peer group data
establishing qc ranges for new lots
based on other laboratory performance
using your own methods and it helps
patients
by assuring that your laboratory quality
matches peers in the industry
here's an example this is for glucose
hexokinase on an abbott architect
you can see that our lab performance the
month
and our cumulative for level one two and
three is in the first
columns in the middle of this table then
column next to it uh to the right is the
peer group
month and cumulative and the method
group
is all method manufacturers so our
cumulative laboratory performance is 55
compared to the peer group of 55.16
and over this recent month we've dropped
down just a little bit
to 54.84 so this allows us to compare
on the same quality control with using
the same methodology
to our peers um throughout the world
and the number of labs there was 38
labs that were using the same methods
same same qc material
now we also want to look at setting our
ranges too tight
we want to be careful because we may be
troubleshooting
too often or too frequently and this is
a waste of resources
so part of a peer comparison is uh
readjusting making sure
that you're matching your means uh your
peers
out there and not just that the mean is
is matching
but that your standard deviations or
your coefficient of variation
uh in terms of the width of your ranges
is reasonable
here we have a low level tsh control
the month is 0.58
or 0.058 that gives us a
cv of 3.11 our cumulative
is about 4.49 so uh we're running a
little bit up
from our cumulative that's 0.0556
on this particular analyzer we have a
set point of 0.055
so our cumulative is very close to our
set point so a little wider you can see
5.45 but when we look at the peer report
we're seeing our peers are running
closer to 12
now that's expected because you have
more labs more variability
the more analyzers you group into this
pool
but it also makes us scratch your head
are we
clearly less than half of our peers uh
do we have that type of performance
given that biologic variation for tsh
at this level is closer to 30 to 40
percent
so we're a sixth of biologic variation
and a clear half of our peers
so we may be too tight
you know we've done multiple
troubleshooting recalibration
maintenance but the fusi is still
running high so the next step to
reconsider
is really changing the set point across
all of our analyzers we had four or five
analyzers that were running tsh
we set the setpoint to the mean of those
and
adjusted our cv upwards
to closer to 10 which made it closer to
um our peer group and now look at the
plot
you can see that many of these outliers
and red
dots that we had been troubleshooting
before
we're really within reasonable
performance
for that particular methodology and we
probably were
over troubleshooting with this so it's
something to always keep in mind and
consider
i'll remind you that quality control
data iso
15189 the laboratory shall have a
procedure to prevent the release of
patient results
in the event of a quality control
failure this is what i've been
describing
troubleshooting as well as review on a
monthly basis or periodic basis
to make sure that your qc is in range
and you're matching your peers
bidirectional communication with lis
your laboratory information systems and
other middleware
allows the laboratory to prevent the
instrument from releasing suspicious
results
you can place your samples on hold until
the error has been corrected
and troubleshooted fix the analyzer and
the method performance
you can also be traceable uh in through
your middleware
to indicate when your last village you
see without
help you when patient look back the
laboratory shall also evaluate the
results from patients that were examined
after the last successful quality
control event
so programs like bio-rad unity real time
can assist you in compliance with iso
regulations and even cap and
clear regulations in the united states
i'm going to close by wrapping up with
some
qc take-home messages do
calculate your own quality control
limits from your lab data
don't necessarily utilize what's in the
package insert
use computer and statistics to analyze
and interpret quality control data
and select qc procedures to detect
medically important errors
define your total allowable error and
your error budget
for each test hold patient samples
when controls go out of range
troubleshoot the root cause
of out of control conditions and fix
those problems
don't just repeat quality control until
they come back
in do review your qc regularly
daily weekly monthly comment your
corrective actions
and monitor your ongoing performance
using interlaboratory quality control
programs
like bio biorad unity but also
external quality assurance programs like
proficiency testing
to make sure you're matching your peers
don't
adjust your qc too frequently
wait till there's a scientifically valid
reason
i want to thank you for your attention
and i will turn it over
for questions and answers
thank you dr nichols for that
informative presentation we will now
start the live q a portion of the
webinar
if you have any questions you want to
ask please do so now
just click on that ask a question box
located on the far
left of your screen so let's get started
dr nichols it looks like we already have
some great questions coming in from our
audience
our first question when starting a new
qc lot do you advise to use
10 or 20 data points to estimate
your new mean so
clsi recommends using at least
10 points so analyzing
that quality control at least once a day
over 10 days
at a minimum but if you want to get a
better estimate if this is a brand new
control material that you don't have a
lot of experience with
you want to see how it captures
performance on
multiple calibrations multiple reagent
lots
multiple operators you may need to
analyze that quality control
for a longer period of time like 20 days
or even longer thank you so much and
what is your recommended practice when
an assay
is statistically out of control but
within the total allowable
error so i talked a little bit of uh
gave a couple examples of this
um clearly you want it within the total
allowable error but uh if you see shifts
of performance
outside of your predetermined quality
control ranges
you need to troubleshoot that try
repeating the qc look at
whether your reagent is at the end of
the bottle
you may want to add a new pack or new
bottle of reagent on the analyzer
double check your calibration when was
it last calibrated
also look at instrument maintenance
thank you so much dr nichols and our
next audience number wants to know
what west guard rules do you recommend
that we follow it seems that one to
two's is too restrictive
sure if you go one to two s remember
that
the random chance of one in 20 um
five percent will just randomly be
outside of range
um so you know if you're using that as a
failure
you're going to be troubleshooting a lot
more frequently
than if you used a wider range like a 1
3s type of rule but you really need to
tailor your quality control rules and
pick your quality control rules
to the method itself the performance of
that method
is it a very stable method you want to
probably use
wider ranges maybe fewer rules
if it's very unstable you see lots of
frequent ships
uh it's uh your techs are constantly
troubleshooting the analyzer
with that method you want to maximize
your
quality control you can estimate this
with sigma rules
sigma which is based on your total
allowable
error for that analyte your
precision and your truth or
bias of that method those come together
for a sigma
world-class sigma is six sigma for
factories
uh and the industry if you are
at six sigma you can go with fewer
quality control rules
if you are at lower sigma three
uh or lower you want to maximize the
number of rules that you use
thank you so much i want to thank our
audience for these great questions
coming in
we have time for a couple of more how
often
should you run qc events on point of
care instruments
sure so it depends on the methodology
number one you have to follow
manufacturer's recommendations meaning
looking at the frequency that's
recommended
in the package insert that's at a bare
minimum
but then you can go with a frequency
that is based on
your local requirements in the united
states
it's based on clear regulations and you
need to
basically run quality control for
non-waived
methodologies run at least two levels
each day of patient testing
or you can develop a through risk
management
individualized quality control plan that
will allow you to reduce the frequency
of qc
in lieu of some built-in or internal
processes that are present on a lot of
our
point-of-care testing methodologies so
it's dependent on the method
dependent on your local regulations but
typically it is a minimum
you see once a day or using an
alternative like risk management to
reduce that frequency
two weekly monthly
thank you so much we have time for one
more question if the controls and
analyzer are from the same company
can we use the ranges that are
pre-printed that came with those
controls
keep in mind those quality control
ranges
cover multiple probably models of
analyzer
that one manufacturer may be uh
releasing
or supporting even though they
are matched from the manufacturer with
that particular models and
makes of analyzers so those are usually
much
wider than are acceptable for clinical
performance
and they really set more as this is the
target that you should be shooting
for where those quality control should
fall but then each laboratory should
really be determining their
individual ranges based on their
specific
analyzers and the specific lots of
reagents
and calibrators they're using
dr nichols i want to thank you for your
time today for your important research
and before we go i also want to thank
our audience for joining us today
and for their questions and questions we
do not have
will be answered and posted in the event
resources
by may 28th and this webcast will be
available on demand in the auditorium
from thursday on
if you found this informative and
helpful please share it with your
colleagues
for the next webinar on june 30th we
will have
dr lauren buckman from virginia
commonwealth university medical center
presenting best practices to recover
from an out of control
event please stay tuned and watch your
email
inbox for the invitation until next time
take care and stay healthy everyone bye